hello this is exciting a couple of
months ago I did a show and an Indian
casino hold your applause and I brought
my husband with me we're parking the car
and he says you know the one thing that
makes me sad about Indian casinos and I
said the one thing just the one what is
it what's the one thing and he said the
fact that there's no Native American
restaurants at the Indian casinos how
great would that be Native American
restaurant at the Indian casino Wow you
know as an affluent white couple if we
could just find a couple of Indians ago
could you guys do one more thing for us
just couple hominy burgers and some fry
bread no no I get it
there's a reason why there are no Native
American restaurants at the Indian
casino
my fellow Americans it is because we are
a melting pot a pot of melting Ness
everyone takes their ethnic food and we
put it into the melting pot and then it
brings us closer together and then we do
a very American thing where we pick up
the melting pot and we move it into the
frozen food aisle now I don't know if
you know any Native Americans I do turns
out they are not big melters not a
melting people don't want to still mad I
get that I totally get that but here's
the thing about frozen food once frozen
that's no longer ethnic food that's
that's American food once it's frozen
it's ours a frozen taquito has not seen
a Mexican woman in 100 years
but every six-year-old in the world
knows what it is and loves them brings
us closer together the frozen food aisle
is already a trophy case to American
imperialism it's already happened so
what I want the Native Americans to do
is to take all that rage and pour it
into a frozen food line a boxed food
line they could call it manifest destiny
and although all the profits could be
used to buy land who cares they can take
all that rage and it could be a poke in
the historical eye every single product
it could be like those are some reason
you don't want to buy Trail of Tears mix
does it make you does it make you sad
when you think about pigs in a smallpox
blanket how about just a case of sitting
Red Bull I have a dozen of these
Sacagawea teas now here is how I know
that it works here's how because six
months ago I'm in Indiana talking to an
old white guy and in the course of that
conversation old white guy says to me
have you ever had this pod tie have you
ever had this Thai food pod tie yeah
yeah I have have you ever had pod tie
and he goes yeah yeah I had a Lean
Cuisine pod tie it was real nice it was
like spaghetti but with peanuts yes yes
that's exactly what it was my friend
from Lean Cuisine and then he said you
know what I bet you those Thai people
there's some real nice oriental people
those Thai people then I stare to them
for a second he said I don't think I'm
supposed to say
oriental so we can all be taught my
fellow Americans we learn things I lived
here in Los Angeles and my favorite
thing about Los Angeles is that we're
the only ones still in the world that
are still making up jobs and industries
and careers out of nothing out of boof
out of whole cloth everything to do with
your dog or your kid or you don't walk
it or wash it that's us out-of-work
actors and comedians makeup jobs all the
time and I when I travel and I see a
Pilates studio and I do all I can think
is you're welcome
we made that up Pilates isn't real you
guys
but there's once the rest of the world
hasn't seen yet nobody has seen
TaskRabbit nobody's seen pink dot
TaskRabbit we'll do your errands for you
pink donald deliver anything you want
day your night two in the morning two in
the afternoon I need a box of pop-tarts
and a crescent wrench you'll say they'll
send a man to Walmart that Kyle come
over to your house you'll give him $70
you'll continue to do blow or whatever
creepy thing you're doing and I was
trying to think what wouldn't pink dot
deliver and like if I called him up at
3:00 in the morning and I said I need
one bullet ooh an integer no I I like
that you haven't being delivered once
and but you got a start
you gotta start your own business you
always do I've already registered family
pet ancestry.com I've registered it I've
registered it because one day you're
gonna want to know if your cat came over
on the Mayflower you're gonna want to
know if your dog is eligible to be a dog
of the American Revolution and join the
DAR and I'm gonna be there for you thank
you so much you guys
[Applause]
you